hey guys embarrass here I talk a lot
about morning routines on Tim Ferriss
show with 200 plus world class experts
now you tend to spot certain patterns
and I'm also a fan of experimenting with
some of the weirder stuff so what do I
do at night what is my evening winddown
protocol and what do I do if I'm on the
road and I don't have something like a
sauna or an ice bath or these very space
and resource consuming contraptions that
I might want to have right like the
chili pad not going to travel the chili
pad even though Rick Rubin and Laird
Hamilton and all these people Kelly
Starrett swear by it it's a big-ass
contraption so what can you do I will
show you a few of the tools of the trade
as far as I'm concerned that I'm using
right now pre bed to help me sleep
because as someone who's had or had Ashe
today insomnia for decades sleep has
always been compromised and as a result
it is now on my highest priorities I'll
show you some biochemical good is this
is certainly a cheaper version of it but
this is phosphatidylserine right what is
this Pospisil seryan sometimes called PS
possible sharing was recommended to me
by an MD who noticed that he since he
was wearing a continuous glucose monitor
meaning he's not a diabetic but he was
wearing a Dexcom device that's inserted
into the skin so that he'd get a readout
on his iPhone at all times I'm a graph
of his blood glucose so he's having
trouble sleeping and what he realized
was because he had so many projects
running he does a lot more than just
handle high-end medical clients he was
having bursts of cortisol at night so
just when he was trying to go to bed he
would get a burst of cortisol that would
cause the release of glucose I suppose
by breaking down glycogen in the liver
or muscle and phosphorus arranged
specifically it's not like an ambien or
anything along those lines or melatonin
let's say that's a circadian trigger
what this is doing is blunting cortisol
release
so by blunting the cortisol release
taking this perform bed you then blood
the glucose release which causes you to
wake up
like you're having a sugar high in the
middle of the night and lo and behold
his sleep quality improves so I don't
use this all the time
cortisol is a very important hormone you
don't want to inhibit it completely or
you would die so occasional use maybe
when I'm first getting settled in a new
air B&B or hotel FASTA feel serene very
very useful that is number one number
two now I won't actually carry this in
my bag but as soon as I land somewhere I
will buy one of these or use instacart
to get a bottle it depends on how long
I'll be there whether its large or small
of bragh raw unfiltered apple cider
vinegar and I will have at least one or
two tablespoons of this in water when I
wake up and also when I go to bed I
cannot explain exactly why this has the
effect it does just mechanistically I
don't know how to exactly explain a
plausible mechanism but there are two
things that I use this for the first is
immune support so having apple cider
vinegar and also whey protein in the
mornings just through some incredibly
harrowing book launches and other
incredible deadlines I've noticed
supplements anything I might be doing to
support my immune system and I just I
get less sick if I do become sick it's
of less duration and severity so apple
cider vinegar helpful for that it would
appear also very helpful as a tip from
Seth Roberts PhD sadly has passed
professor emeritus at boos UC Berkeley
who suggested for insomnia one
tablespoon or two tablespoons of apple
cider vinegar one tablespoon of raw
honey mixed in hot water and for I'd say
eight out of ten people that just knocks
you out so if I'm really having trouble
sleeping I'll also use that now oddly
enough you would think well wait a
second if I'm using this to blunt
glucose release and then I'm drinking
this not at the same time I don't use
these together with honey wouldn't honey
also trigger the same type of sugar I
for whatever reason done twenty or
thirty minutes before bed it has the
opposite effect
go figure alright these are these are
two now beyond that I'll very frequently
do a slant board workout which isn't
really work out because I'm really
holding it I step on this in different
ways this is designed by Eric Horton who
became famous from Born to Run this is
the Frio Frio gear calm slant board /
wobble board I have no connection to
this company easy to travel with I mean
super simple to throw in a bag and I
will spend 30 to 60 seconds in different
ways positioning my foot and improving
my stability and the lower leg super
easy to travel with I've had a huge ROI
on very little exercise doing that then
I'm going to do what the supple leopard
himself Kelly Starrett would recommend a
few devices that I use to activate I
want to say the parasympathetic am I
getting that right to go to bed pretty
sure it's parasympathetic it's
sympathetic
I'm sure the internet will let me know
but to effectively down regulate my
system and help getting to sleep there
are a few types of soft tissue
manipulation that I like to use this is
a device from the rad company or it is
rad roller this is for your back you can
use it for legs as well notice the spine
fits nicely in this little groove so
you're not jacking up your vertebra
rolling on something that's too hard and
it's very small
the next is something that I will use
just for IT band primarily and vastus
lateralis that's on the side of the leg
so you're really just going to be
rolling your legs out like this and I
will also roll out my hamstrings but
after a long day of standing and or
sitting this is a godsend
so these knobby novice are from the
rumble roller company no no that's the
name of their parent company they're
also stands that you can put these in
that are tiny and you can stick this on
the floor and say roll your feet out on
these but I use this primarily on my
and hamstrings there are many different
devices you can find if you look for
rolling stick you can find other options
and you don't have to do necessarily all
of these but I will almost always do at
least one of them prior to bed my prior
to that I'm in a half hour prior to bed
then this is the deflated ball that you
can blow up with your mouth and then lay
on so that it is pressing into your
abdominal cavity and really just roll
around if you don't know what you're so
as is look that up psoas deep deep
muscle that is very painful to have
someone work on manually but you can you
can really turn your body down a few
gears you can downshift in such a way
that is very helpful prior to bed by
rolling around on your stomach for
literally 30 seconds to 60 seconds I
find that a little to be very helpful
and then last I'm going to show you an
app that I find very very helpful and
the app is called apnea trainer it's
designed for free divers I'm not a free
diver I use it just to relax prior to
going to bed it also improves lung
capacity so that's apnea trainer and you
can see I've already set effectively the
duration that I would like to use and
there's pranayama breathing and then
there's regular apnea training and it's
based on your maximum inhale time so
this is going to be a little boring for
a second but you'll get the idea so
let's try to make sure you can get the
audio inhale five four three two one
hold your breath
ten
five four three two one
exhale ten
five four three two one
inhale five four three two one
hold your breath you get the idea and if
you do that
forget about luck meditation is great
but for the vast majority people who are
averse to it you don't think about that
way just think about it as a five-minute
period of breath work and do say ten
cycles of that where in this particular
case the ratio is 1 for 2 so if I
breathe in for 5 seconds I'm holding for
20 then I'm exhaling for 10 and you do
that especially listening to some
hypnotic robotic female voice counting
off for you
you do that for five minutes your sleep
will come a lot faster and a lot harder
then it would otherwise and super super
simple I'm not sure how much the app
cost a few dollars it's not expensive
and that folks is effect in effect my
little travel yields so all these things
then I put right here - this which I
would order or buy when I land or get
through instacart or something all this
just came out of my suitcase which is
about 20 feet that direction because I
just got back from an extended trip and
this was sitting in there it is my go-to
toolkit for winding down in the evening
or Endor as a pre bed ritual so there
you have it good luck sleep well thanks
for watching guys I hope you enjoyed it
and if you want to see more I have some
fantastic stuff coming including
collaborations just click here and you'd
be the first to see it